hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor and today we're talking about
the four different kinds of
hypersensitivities so first what is a
hypersensitivity well a hypersensitivity
is an undesirable or an actually harmful
reaction of a person's immune system
sometimes also called an intolerance
specifically when we're talking about
sort of more undesirable things rather
than harmful things but but an
intolerance can be used to discuss all
of them so now let's talk about those
four different types
starting with type 1 type 1
hypersensitivity are when a specific
antibody specifically IgE recognizes
soluble antigen remember here that I G
stands for immunoglobulin which is
another name for antibody IgE is one of
the major types of antibodies so IgE
recognizes soluble antigen what does
this mean an antigen is just the thing
being recognized by the immune system in
this case it is something soluble so
it's not something that is cellular or
at the tissue level it's recognizing
just something that's kind of dissolved
and floating around in the body in
particular with type 1 hypersensitivity
IgE is recognizing things like pet
dander mold pollen things like that that
we think of as being related to seasonal
allergies and so IDE binds to that
soluble antigen when it finds it this
triggers an immune system cells called
mast cells to do something called 2d
granulate so the mast cells D granulate
and all that means is they basically
just fill out their guts these mast
cells are full sort of signaling
compounds that are then just released
into the body and the major one here
that we're concerned with is something
called histamine
you might recognize that word because it
is anti histamines that we take when we
want to relieve allergy symptoms and
that's because histamine release causes
the allergy symptoms that we associate
with a lot of these seasonal allergies
are pet allergies so I'm talking about
coughing sneezing red eyes watery eyes
hives those are all being caused by this
mask of histamine release and the body
and antihistamines can help to control
those symptoms so that is type 1
hypersensitivity now let's talk about
type 2 type 2 is also mediated by
antibodies but by different kinds of
antibodies rather than IgE the
antibodies that are in these type 2
hypersensitivity are IgG and IgM and
they recognize rather than the soluble
antigen stuff just happening to be
floating through the body they're
recognizing cellular antigens so
antigens that are actually on the
surface of the host cells and what this
does is when these antibodies recognize
and bind to cellular antigens they're
essentially biting to cells and causing
a lot of damage to those cells this can
be termed Saito Saito Purcell toxicity
so cytotoxicity is when cells are being
damaged some examples of type 2
hypersensitivity
are the recognition of certain cells
antigens self antigens means something
that is self something that belongs to
the host that is not a foreign entity
and this results in conditions known as
autoimmune disorders or autoimmunity
so some of these type 2 hypersensitivity
where you have IgG and IgM are you guys
any cellular antigens and caused some
damage to the cells this can be sort of
self cells and it can also in particular
the red blood cells so the [ __ ] groups if
you've heard like type a Type B type O 2
ad that has to do with carbohydrates
that are on the surface of red blood
cells and also if you've heard about
being like a positive or negative that a
positive and that negative is referring
to RH antigens which are also just
carbohydrates that are um stuck on to
red blood cells and so what can actually
happen here is if the immune system if
these antibodies recognize either the
[ __ ] or the RH antigens on red blood
cells as being floor and they start to
attack red blood cells and this is what
can be dangerous with blood transfusions
so hemolytic blood transfusions when
someone gets a transfusion of blood that
is not sort of compatible with their
blood type that is because these
antibodies are attacking these red blood
cells that are being put into the body
from a foreign source that aren't
compatible also you may have heard of
hemolytic disease of the newborn this is
when a mother's immune system actually
starts to attack the baby's blood when
the baby is sort of still in in utero or
just afterwards because of this sort of
incompatibility where the mom's
antibodies start to attack attack on
recognizing the baby's
different antigens now let's talk about
type 3 hypersensitivity type 3
hypersensitivity are specifically
characterized by these things called
immune complexes immune complexes are
when you have aggregations of antibody
and soluble antigen so not just one
antibody recognizing one soluble antigen
but multiple antibiotics
recognizing more than one soluble
antigen at a time buying into more than
one at a time and then those same
soluble antigens will be bound by other
antibodies and you just get this large
mass of all of these soluble antigens
that are being recognized by all of
these antibodies at once and that's
called an immune complex and the immune
complex will deposit into blood vessel
walls and once it's deposited into the
blood vessel walls it causes a couple of
things that happen first of all it
causes complement Cascades complement
are types of proteins that are part of
the immune system that cause this
cascade where all these complement
proteins are activating other complement
proteins and they eventually lead to
something called a membrane attack
complex where they form a hole in a cell
and bust it open and kill it and when
this is happening this is happening in
the body to host cells rather than to
pathogens when complement cascade
results in the death of pathogen so it's
a good thing when they result in the
death of host cells like in type 3
hypersensitivity that's a bad thing
something else that happened to meet
immune complexes deposit into blood
vessel walls is neutrophil degranulation
we had previously mentioned and type 1
hypersensitivity x' with mast cells need
granulating but that means they just
still forth and sort of secrete all
there all of these components that are
held inside themselves and for
neutrophils this means a lot of sort of
cytotoxic enzymes a lot of enzymes that
are meant to degrade and break down
things and so my complement starts to
have its cascade and neutrophils d
granulate there's all of the sort of
damage that's being done and this
results in widespread inflammation in
the body so lots of information lots of
tissue damage an example of this is the
autoimmune disorder lupus which you
might have heard of before and the lupus
is where antibodies bind either to self
DNA or to self proteins remember when we
have self antigens
like antibodies people that autoimmunity
so this is another place where
autoimmune disorders happen specifically
being caused by these immune complexes
and causing the sort of systemic
diseases like lupus now let's move on to
the final type of hypersensitivity type
4 type 4 is different than the first
three types in particular because it is
cell mediated it is actually regulated
by t-cells
so whereas types one and two and three
all involved antibodies doing something
that was going to harm the host type
four it's about t-cells doing something
wrong so the T cells can be th one or
th2 cells four different kinds of T
helper cells can also be cytotoxic
lymphocytes it's a different kind of T
cell but either way it's considered cell
mediated rather than antibody mediated
and it's also known as a delayed type of
hypersensitivity so delayed
hypersensitivity and all this means is
that the T cells they start to attack
something that otherwise shouldn't be
harmful in order to get it out of the
body this results and things like latex
allergies poison ivy the rash the
dermatitis that you get from contact
with poison ivy
it also transplant rejection so if you
hear about someone who maybe got a lung
transplant and then their body rejected
it that is because of a type 4
hypersensitivity where the T cells
recognized either the latex or the
poison ivy or the the lung transplant
one of these things and said hey that
shouldn't be here and they have this
really strong sort of overreaction to
eliminate what they do as a threat and
it results in either sort of an allergy
or a rash or at worst a major rejection
of the needle
organ transplant and known as a delayed
hypersensitivity because it can take
several days sometimes for these things
to for the symptoms to appear so several
days following following explosion
exposure in some cases and so that is
sort of it for the four types of
hypersensitivity I have another video
specifically on on antibody on antibody
structure and function and so if you're
interested in learning more about some
of these antibodies what they look like
what they do and then please check out
that video and thanks for watching
biology professor